don't agree with you but no i'm saying  that they're willing to check other  places that they won't normally go with  okay but i wanted to ask you a question  so based on you know your stats and your  experience and your knowledge what would  you advise a woman like me two kids  divorced  what would i advise you yeah when it  comes to dating i would say you probably  want to date a man with kids who's a  little bit older okay  how do you 30 yeah  looking like the 40s after 45 range 40  25 yeah because older men who have  already established themselves yeah  older men have already established  themselves they have no problem with a  woman like that it's the younger men  like a 30 year old man i wouldn't date a  third year old man even if i didn't so  you dated someone older yeah